das war real das war gruselig druck nach
oben merkt dass der ganze himmel sich
einfährt nach einer kurzen reise ich wie
lauter kleine teile wie tropfen aus
diesen wolken rauskommen und praktisch
nach unten kommen aber wie in zeitlupe
es ist eine tragödie die sich ereignet
am ersten juli 2002 um 23 uhr 35 über
der stadt überlingen am bodensee stoßen
zwei flugzeuge zusammen
herbert dreiseitel ist in dieser nacht
mit dem fahrrad unterwegs vom büro nach
hause allein ich habe dann gemerkt die
teile kommen hoffentlich zugeflogen du
hast aber keine chance man kann auch dem
nicht ausweichen ja also man kann
eigentlich nur dastehen und hoffen dass
es nichts eintrifft es war natürlich
nachtmann konnte das nicht sehen dass
das leichen von kindern auch waren die
darunter gefallen sind aber für mich im
nachhinein noch mal erschütternd ich war
praktisch mitten drin und direkt unten
drunter
71 menschen sterben bei dem unglück
darunter 49 kinder sie sind unterwegs in
so einer tupolew von moskau nach
barcelona ihr flugzeug kollidiert in
fast 11.000 metern höhe mit einer
frachtmaschine die von bergamo nach
brüssel fliegt niemand überlebt den
unfall
die wrackteile verstreut über 30
quadratkilometer
in den folgenden tagen untersuchen 1000
helfende die trümmer und bergen leichen
feuerwehrleute technisches hilfswerk
flugexperten polizei sie durchkämmen
jeden quadratmeter in diesem riesigen
areal stellen alles sicher was sie
finden können der rumpf der
passagiermaschine liegt in dieser
apfelplantage darin
27 tote die bergung der opfer lief
relativ ruhig ab weil man immer stück
für stück dieses zertrümmerte flugzeug
zerlegt hat und im gleichen atemzug die
opfer so wie man sie vorgefunden hat aus
ihren sitzen oder aus der situation wie
sie dort lagen geborgen hat wir hatten
nicht die angst irgendein opfer
vielleicht zu verlieren dass wir es
nicht mehr retten können sondern es ging
hier um die bergung und die
identifikation der opfer alle toten
können sie damals bergen und
identifizieren unglaublich fast dass
hier am boden niemand zu schaden kommt
dass die flugzeugteile allesamt auf
feldern in gärten oder im wald landen
die leute sind sehr dankbar wir haben
einen ganzen tragischen unglück auf dem
boden ein unwahrscheinliches glück
gehabt dass es dort zu keinen verletzten
gekommen ist auch die trümmer und die
piloten der dhl frachtmaschine stürzen
auf unbewohntes gebiet
ist sehr oft trüb und spekuliert worden
ob die hier einfach unter gefallen ist
oder vielleicht auch bewusst hier zu
fall gebracht wurde durch die piloten um
hier die in der nähe liegenden
ortschaften nicht zu gefährden
ob die piloten noch eingreifen beim
absturz aufgeklärt ist das nicht
taras kost enkel russischer angehöriger
damals 21 jahre alt verliert beim
unglück seine schwester sie begleitet
die schülerinnen und schüler auf ihrer
reise oxana fehlt ihm so bis heute
sie war nicht nur meine schwester
sondern auch meine freundin sie war so
gebildet hat mit ihren 30 jahren so viel
gelesen sie hat mir zugehört mich
erzogen andere freunde können sie nicht
ersetzen
am vierten juli 2002 drei tage nach der
katastrophe reiste er mit seinen eltern
und all den anderen angehörigen nach
überlingen um abschied zu nehmen
im flugzeug lernte ich die anderen
angehörigen kennen und obwohl wir uns
gerade erst bekannt machten hatten wir
das gefühl dass wir in unserer trauer
schon lange eng verbunden waren
irina petschar dina und ihre freundinnen
sind damals auch vor ort nämlich als
übersetzerinnen sie holen die
angehörigen ab vom flughafen
und die angehörige sind dann diese diese
treppe der quasi unter aus dem flieger
herausgegangen ja mit blumen mit kopien
mit grenzen und so weiter und klar
alliance schwarz sie haben dann ihre
grenze ihre blumen das alles hier
niedergelegt und das war das war ganz
schlimm da stand so geschreie geweine
unter das immer noch wenn ich rede jetzt
sogar glücklich so ganz ganz schlimm
weiß noch wo die dolmetscher bei der
polizei für die identifizierung
übersetzt haben neben ihr sitzt eine
mutter die ihr kind verloren hat und die
beschreibt das kind augenfarbe motor
male was für strukturen gehalten haben
was für kleidung usw das war das
schlimmste moment an dem tag
so viele sicherheitsvorkehrungen so viel
platz am himmel wie kann es überhaupt zu
so ein zusammenstoß kommen die
katastrophe beginnt damit dass beide
flugzeuge kurz vor dem zusammenstoß
aufeinander zurasen in gleicher höhe und
erstmal auch in dieser höhe bleiben
erklärt damals der pressesprecher der
deutschen flugsicherung
also anderthalb minuten hätten
normalerweise ausgereicht dieses problem
zu lösen doch im tower in zürich an
diesem abend technische probleme und zum
zeitpunkt der kollision nur ein einziger
fluglotse am platz axel raab ist bis
heute fassungslos es liegt so viel
schief bei der verantwortlichen firma
sky galt und man muss leider auch sagen
dass der fluglotse in dem moment völlig
versagt hat und völlig die falschen
anweisung gegeben hat
erst im letzten augenblick befiehlt er
dem russischen piloten zu sinken ein
fataler fehler denn das
kollisionswarnsystem an bord gibt die
gegenteilige anweisung nämlich steigen
doch der pilot geht runter erfolgt dem
nutzen
die andere maschine folgt dem computer
und geht auch runter und jetzt sieht man
hier beide in der gleichen höhe und
gleich kommt es dann zum crash trifft
den russischen piloten eine mitschuld
weil er auf den lotsen und nicht auf den
computer hörte er hat dem computer zu
folgen allerdings bis dahin war das eine
soll vorschrift es hat geheißen er soll
dem computer folgen das wurde nach dem
unglück geändert in er muss den computer
folgen der fluglotse bezahlt seinen
fehler mit dem leben vor seinem haus
bringt ihn 2004 einer der angehörigen um
witali kalojew kommt über den verlust
von frau und kindern nicht hinweg der
ist dort gestanden und
ich kann es nicht anders sagen in sich
hinein geweint er wurde nie laut aber er
zitterte
man hat ihm seinen großen schmerz und
seine verzweiflung deutlich angesehen
carola wird ein anderer mensch äußerlich
wie innerlich der friedhof in russland
wo seine familie beigesetzt ist er wird
zum mittelpunkt seines lebens
nach der tat verurteilt ihn ein
schweizer gericht zu fünf jahren und
drei monaten gefängnis für vorsätzliche
tötung eine geringe strafe
erst 2007 werden vier skyguide
mitarbeiter zur verantwortung gezogen
sie bekommen bewährungsstrafen wegen
mehrfacher fahrlässiger tötung
karas ist durch den tod seiner schwester
mit überlingen sehr verbunden im märz
dieses jahres ist er mit seiner
schwangeren ukrainischen frau aus calw
hierher geflohen er ist in überlingen
vater geworden
das ist hier zu meiner heimat geworden
auch oxana liebte deutschland sie hätte
gerne hier gelebt
die opfer des unglücks sie kommen aus
der russischen stadt ufa deshalb reist
der verein der die gedenkstätte bis
heute pflegt brücke nach ufa die
verbindung aufrecht zu erhalten zwischen
überlingen und den angehörigen das ist
ihnen wichtig deren schicksal ist ihm
bis heute so nah
also berührt nach wie vor viele sachen
sind wie als ob es gestern gewesen wäre
das schmerzt vielleicht noch mehr wenn
man denkt ja mein kind wäre jetzt
soundso viele jahre alt und hätte
vielleicht eine familie und wie wäre es
wenn es damals nicht passiert wäre
es ist passiert am ersten juli vor genau
20 jahren
[Musik]